let's start with something a little
different today I I kind of like this
quite a bit Byron Donald's and Jamal
Bowman are two members of Congress Byron
Donalds is a republican from Florida
Jamal Bowman is a Democrat representing
New York they had a debate of sorts on
the steps of the capital in Washington
D.C and it is cartoonish in a way
there's not like deep policy substance
here but I would much prefer this debate
to what we've seen recently in terms of
our elected officials engaging in so
let's take a look at this this happening
on the steps of the capital in DC you
will see Byron Donald's on on the left
of the screen and then Jamal Bowman will
pop up and be on the right of the screen
what I will say first for the
gentleman from New York man listen
it's cool I have two people in my state
that could be president I don't know
about New York that's all I'm gonna say
though that's all I'm saying
[Music]
they're like uh it's really not that but
people are trying to raise a fuss I've
had the conversations that's not true
why can't uh
into our release who have done their
time why can't they be re-enfranchised
and be allowed to vote they are in our
state
who's the second guy second person come
on now you already know that Trump and
Ron I'm Trump
so Trump claims Florida now he
knows
three years now
I said that's what he said that's what
he said to Kathy oh he told Kathy
Holcomb like so I got to go both those
dudes gonna get crushed
oh
the man of 1600 correction please if she
wanted to jump in she would kill both of
them secondly Biden will kill both of
them buying them past three
this is arguably the best part here
coming up
fighting past three bipartisan pieces of
legislation after an Insurrection during
a global pandemic open back up to some
movies
in what world come on in what world
bizarre land ships infrastructure bills
safer communities uh historic investors
to climate 35 insulin High inflation
over on Southern border depending on
everybody's streets we could do the same
thing I could do the same thing
all right so so listen what what did we
learn right
only one person there was actually armed
with facts okay that that's the reality
it was Jamal Bowman but they were at
least relatively more substantive
discussions than Jewish space lasers
woke masks uh trans whatever the case
may be now this was not a debate in the
sense that you can't really debate with
someone who's simply refusing to
acknowledge basic facts you can't and
Donald's is of course complicit in the
hate and the anger that is driving
Republican voters to do what they do
that's all very sad right so I'm not
saying oh two good faith participants
and whatever fine but notice that
whenever policy accomplishments are
brought up there by Jamal Bowman
Byron Donald's can say nothing but no
stop stop no when Bowman cites actual
Biden accomplishments and this is what
the right has they have in their worst
cases right like Marjorie Taylor green
they have that completely unhinged
rhetoric in the best cases where it's
sort of congenial and generally speaking
respectful as this was they still have
nothing more on policy and that's
extraordinarily telling and then of
course the fact that Byron Donalds
thinks we have we have such Rich we have
a richness of candidates in Florida
we've got Trump
and we've got to say at this now I don't
know that I share Bowman's confidence
that Biden would wipe the floor with
DeSantis that remains to be seen But if
more of the conversations among our
elected officials were like this I mean
I'd rather them be more like the Lincoln
Douglas debates okay but that ship seems
to have sailed a couple hundred years
ago if they were more like this than
what we normally get I actually would
prefer it let me know what you think
Kyle Rittenhouse was found not guilty of
criminal charges for killing multiple
people at his criminal trial but is now
being sued by the family of one of the
men he shot dead in 2020.
and by Gage gross kreutz as well whom he
injured Kyle Rittenhouse is begging just
begging people on Tucker Carlson's show
send me money because it's so unfair
what they're doing to me uh the funniest
part and and this really is funny
when the time comes for ritten house to
give the URL where you can donate to him
he mangles the URL this is the whole
reason he was on the show this that
check this out no idea oh and just to be
let me explain one other thing
he's being sued civilly remember you can
be found criminally Not Guilty by the
standard of Reasonable Doubt
and then
responsible civilly for the same death
of an individual that you caused so just
remember that that he's being sued
civilly now no idea it's it's ridiculous
it's lawsuit it's very frustrating and
It's upsetting this is frustrating to me
an attack on our Second Amendment rights
and our rights to self-defense right and
it's saying if you use your god-given
right to self-defense they're going to
come after you if you win a court you're
acquitted rightfully so
they're going to take you to civil court
and they're going to file they're going
to take you for everything you're worth
they're going to drive you into
bankruptcy and drown you in a mountain
of legal bills and I know we're going to
win to court but it's going to be
expensive it's going to cost a lot of
money to fight these attorneys they're
very powerful you can go to
www.givesango.com
okay
www.givesonggo.com I have no clue what
the hell that is our slash cloud rented
house to help me let's hear it once more
attorneys are very powerful you can go
to
www.givesango.com
rented house give Sango to help me take
on these lawyers so they don't come
after more people because if they can
come after me they will come after you
right will they though I'm not sure
about that why would they come up why
would they come after people who haven't
done what Kyle Rittenhouse chose to do
so here's the deal with this he wants
you to think that if he's been acquitted
criminally it's unfair that you should
be able to be sued civilly but that's
just how the system works you know these
these people talk about respect for Law
and Order and all of it this is the way
it works criminal law deals with crimes
considered harmful to society as a whole
murder theft assault Etc criminal law
would punish offenders deter others from
committing similar crimes in some
theoretical sense rehabilitate okay it
doesn't happen too often criminal cases
are initiated by the government the
burden of proof is on the prosecution to
prove the defendant's guilt Beyond a
reasonable doubt if you're found guilty
you might have fines imprisonment or
other forms of punishment the modern
legal system we have is based on common
law developed in England adopted in many
countries like the United States and it
also includes civil law this is a
Bedrock Foundation of our legal system
he might not like it but it is and when
there are disputes between individuals
could be a contractual dispute could be
a personal injury claim which is what
we're talking about here the purpose of
civil law
is cases brought by a plaintiff to
compensate an injured party for the
suffer the harm that they suffered and
civil cases are initiated by the injured
party not the government it's a
different burden which is a
preponderance of evidence sort of like
thinking about
51 likely or that's not actually the way
lawyers would describe it but it is a
different standard and you can be found
not guilty criminally and responsible
civilly if you support law and order if
you claim as Kyle Rittenhouse does to
support all of these different aspects
of of our system this is part of the
system and you can't pick and choose
which is all they want to do he doesn't
like it he also doesn't understand it
similar when Trump said how can they
impeach me again they already impeached
me well it's for something different or
how can they impeach me when Mueller
cleared me well Mueller didn't clear you
of obstruction but it has nothing to do
the Mueller probe has nothing to do with
whether you can be impeached they would
like things to work differently than
they do but this is it pathetic Kyle
Rittenhouse now begging for money and
you can go to a URL I couldn't even
understand I guess uh if you want to
donate CPAC finally started and it's
really humiliating and embarrassing here
is the start of it with Matt schlapp who
runs the event remember much of the
controversy around CPAC this year is
that match lap who is anti-gay
and married to a woman he is accused of
having I I can't even do it he's accused
of having pummeled the junk of another
man uh sexual assault we're talking
about many people didn't want to go to
CPAC here is Matt schlapp uh addressing
Jim Jordan as maybe the most powerful
man in Washington there's a lot of
chatter in the media
here and not here I'm really proud to be
standing alongside someone I think might
just be the most powerful man in
Washington DC
yeah
you know I don't think that Jim Jordan
is at this point the most powerful man
in Washington DC but it's the perfect
person for schlap to point to because
Jordan has quite a history of looking
the other way when bad things are being
done let's just leave it at that
um Kurt schlichter was there and he had
quite an interesting anecdote these are
the sorts of colorful stories we've come
to expect at CPAC clicker my friend from
town hall who has a very important
historic distinction he was kicked off
in banned from the Don Lemon show
I forget what did you say again well so
I'm on I'm on the show and he he says so
this is when we run up to Trump and he
says you know Kirk this is terrible this
is the worst thing ever do you know what
what Donald Trump said and I'm like I
don't know and he says
he said
that Hillary got schlonged when she was
running against uh Barack Obama that was
a good one and I I got I said I don't
care Hillary Clinton I mean you care
about that Hillary Clinton literally
stood by while her husband used an
intern as a humidor whoa and he's
totally normal
you can't say that so I said she sat
there and literally asked goodbye as her
husband used
an intern is a humidor and boot off of
CNN best thing ever happened to me so
that's all right a true tale of
redemption and forgiveness or something
like that uh they're still doing the
election with stolen stuff here is
Stephen Bannon interviewing Kimberly
Guilfoyle and someone else looks like
Miss Miss Indiana maybe or something I
can't tell and uh playing up the entire
Biden's not the legitimate president
stuff you said the bidens were the
occupiers of 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
are you implying they did not win the
2020 election ma'am I'm straight out
saying that they deny I was wearing an
occupier it's like it's like the
equivalent of a squatter right do you
agree with that do you think Joe is Joe
buying the legitimate president I say
no definitely not all right and then a
woman traveled all the way to CPAC I
guess because she loves Steve Bannon and
Steve Bannon suggests not watching Fox
News anymore which is interesting name
and what brings you here today I'm Bobby
Rooney and I actually came here because
I love Donald Trump and I love Steve
Bannon also in real America voice and
I'm I'm with a little group in Pueblo
Colorado who are grandparents for
America and would you say gun parents or
grandparents planting trees under which
we will never sit because we're trying
to get policy
they go and they vote personality we
can't win the personality War right it's
the left that's voting for personality
that oh my goodness that is genius huh
we can win the policy War they're all in
our favor so we didn't brochure that
puts Republicans I'm curious are there
any policies that the country is moving
in their favor I can't think of a single
one policies on one side
if you pick all the Democrat policies
vote that way we just want you not to be
stupid right all right you know know
what you're voting for hold on hold on
ma'am if you don't want to be stupid
stop watching Fox
[Applause]
there were some except for us there did
you hear that he's like except for did
he say except for Maria Bartiromo and
someone else
so this is another unhinged year of CPAC
we will be live later today and then
tomorrow with the Trump speech and it is
it is a Gong Show it really is but
hopefully I don't have to suffer through
it alone and some of you will join me
make sure you're subscribed on the
YouTube channel youtube.com the David
Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David pakman show is
made possible by our viewers and
listeners wherein we have the membership
program and here as it is the way that
we fund the show I invite you to sign up
at joinpakman.com we do have the coupon
code 24 starts now which you can use and
I'll just mention this it's I don't know
I shouldn't really be mentioning it but
we had a tick tock live stream on
February 28th the last day of the month
and we had like a one day only coupon
code Tick Tock Feb and it is a pretty
aggressive coupon code we didn't really
turn the code off at the end of February
so you can still use it and it's like an
even bigger discount Tick Tock Feb let's
get to hearing from some people in the
audience I can't think of anybody more
important than the folks who make this
show possible through their viewership
and listenership we take calls on
Fridays at join Pac-Man davidpackman.com
Discord rather and you can join the
Discord that way let's start today
um with oh I don't know it's so hard to
say how about
Joe from Massachusetts Joe from
Massachusetts welcome let's all hope for
no technical trouble and that we have an
auspicious start today
how do I sound David you sound good what
do you have like a creaky door there
oh that's my chair leaning back I'm my
bad oh no problem maybe some dry lube
would would deal with that noise maybe
it would I'm just gonna stick it up
oh boy now you're starting to cut in and
out Joe let's hope we can get a question
here
I'm just still bad okay now I heard that
okay
Mike's about um George Anthony devalder
Santos yes the third novel Peace Prize
winner
um
first contributions to nuclear fission
um so on my quick disclaimer right
before I get to the question is that he
should resign because his voters voted
for somebody else basically absolutely
but uh my question is I want your take
would it actually be beneficial to the
left
if he stayed on like each week a new a
new line a new Scandal and more
infighting on the right would it
actually benefit the left if he actually
just stayed I think that the way in
which so here's the thing
if George Anthony devolder Santos III
junior senior stays I think the way that
it's useful to the left is that they can
continue to make it a story that this
guy has been allowed to stay by the
Republican party and show how low their
standards are and all these different
things the trick to it is they have to
keep it in the news and they have to
constantly find new lies and things to
talk about because otherwise it'll just
sort of Fade Away you're not going to
get two years out of this unless you can
keep finding new lies
yeah I'm just curious to see where it
all leads up to that's all we can do see
what happens
but honestly it would be correct for him
to be forced to resign that would be the
right thing absolutely yeah yeah I just
wanted to make that disclaimer so 100
yeah thanks for taking my call that was
my first time using a Discord call I'm
glad it didn't go too bad no you did
relatively well after we sorted out that
bridge yeah all right thank you Joe from
Massachusetts great to have you on
all right take care all right there goes
Joe very very powerful declarations made
there let's go next to gets from Alberta
is that Alberta Canada gets
yes that is well welcome
oh man he's trying to the show
um just curious if you've ever seen the
documentary the territory on Disney plus
no I have not what is it
oh it's just an environmental
um that's what indigenous peoples
uh I'm a little nervous you're doing
good people in the Amazon and they're
fighting
um the expansion of this basically
industrial colonization
interesting fantastic watched if you
haven't seen it
um the only ask that I have of your your
show is that it'd be kind of cool if you
had some indigenous speakers talking on
indigenous issues
indigenous to where
uh if it's a North American issue then
grabbing someone from the local nation
that could talk about that
um another with sodens right now are
always in a state of Perpetual
um battle with the oil companies and the
RCMP and they're they have activists
they have land Defenders that would you
know love to talk and spread their
message and raise awareness
I think that's a very interesting idea
we will look into it immediately
yeah that's that I love the show I just
be awesome to see more uh brown and
black people uh specifically people from
those Nations and that's the only ask I
have I think you're amazing
um your debate I don't think was a
debacle it was really weird watching
some guy play 40 chess with himself you
mean you mean the Patrick that David one
are you talking about pbd yeah it was it
was interesting to watch somebody beat
themselves in 4D chess and you're just
sitting back and watching like what are
you talking about there were so many
dimensions that they were playing
against themselves essentially
it was great so that's all I got to say
just it'd be nice to see more indigenous
folks if you need to hook up I can send
some like uh Representatives if you want
a contact information too all right gets
from Alberta I appreciate the suggestion
thank you
ciao all right there he goes gets great
to have him on let's go next to Dan from
Oregon Dan from Oregon welcome to the
David packman show what is on your mind
today
hi David
um so I uh I'm trying to
figure out where I'm at politically
right now uh you know I
was very much a backer of most of the
democratic establishments goals you know
in my younger years and I'm starting to
do more and more research and and look
into how
uh
difficult it is really move the needle
on a lot of these big political issues
with the constant Stranglehold of the
capitalist class and uh just wondering
where where
conversations could go where uh you
think that we can actually move the
needle in getting people to recognize
the
inherent Hill we're trying to climb uh
over
you know these giant changes that need
to be made when there's the big money
influences just constantly uh keeping
their boot on her this is so tough I
mean I wish there was a simple answer
but you're basically saying how can you
circumvent the system that got us to
where we are
without having any system but that
system with which to do it right and
this is this is what makes this stuff so
difficult you accurately diagnose that
there are so many people that aren't
even sort of like aware of the top level
structural and systemic things that need
to happen you know I think that these
things include campaign Finance how we
run elections media you know I've talked
about like my big overarching issues
that affect every issue but we're sort
of limited by using the very broken
system we have to get people to
recognize this stuff and it is the very
same system which makes it so a lot of
people can't afford to take time off in
order to go to a protest and all these
things so I mean listen I could repeat
like the same stuff I always say but
obviously it's not working in any real
way so I don't have an answer and it's
sort of like one of the most critical
questions which is great we've
identified the problems of the system
and now we need to work within that
system in some way like I know you can
say we'll work outside the system right
but so how are we going to communicate
with people we've got social media
traditional media print media you can go
out and do street preaching but we know
kind of how that works so it is a really
difficult question and I wish I had a
better answer
I I realized it was a very broad
question but
um you know I I really
value the way you uh put things out
there uh and I just wanted to hear your
take on that but it's something that I'm
very interested in uh putting some
energy into and learning more about and
uh yeah just uh
I would love to see
some movement in that direction as far
as getting more people on board it's
like crazy to me that I sit and talk to
people that you know
uh consider themselves being on the
right yeah when I
kind of talk about the goals of what you
know we're trying to socialism
essentially would would accomplish
without actually saying socialism they
tend to jump on board real quick and
agree with me but that's interesting
well as you know Dan I am not a
socialist but I still share many of the
same immediate next steps that you would
identify I'm sure
yeah right well we all know that
corporate strangleholders is uh killing
us all all right my friend thank you for
bringing up this important issue I
appreciate it have a good day all right
there goes Dan from Oregon let's welcome
back to the program Johnny from Boston
Johnny welcome you're going to be
watching CPAC at all
oh boy
no you're not watching it okay fair all
right good I have other things to watch
that's fair I totally respect that
um so I wanted to ask about your uh
interview with Pandora box I know it
wasn't on the show but I saw it kind of
on the link I actually suggested to
watch Pandora how did you get connected
with her and how has the response been
so um well my colleague John uh handled
making the initial contact and
um actually Pandora was connected to the
show the dish that I had a cameo on and
so I actually think that was the
connection and the response has been
pretty good I have to tell you I mean
listen the homophobes and the anti-drag
and the anti-trans and everybody in that
space came up with their same
predictable responses but a ton of
people wrote to me saying I learned a
ton about the difference between drag
performers and trans people which I I I
was actually kind of shocked that a lot
of people didn't realize we're talking
about two different things and just
generally people were very positive
about the interview
that's good I loved it I was I was so
excited I actually recorded a podcast
with her drag sister Aggie Dune from
Rochester
um and I was like do you know what she
did she's doing some great she's doing
God's work right now
um and especially with have you heard
about the thing going on in Tennessee
with the governor yeah we covered it
earlier this week where he's doing all
this anti-drag stuff and then he was
confronted with a picture of himself in
Drag
yeah and it's it's like it's crazy
because Nashville has some amazing drag
performers it's like I I really worried
that it's going to put a lot of them out
of work because the bill is really
Draconian it's all crazy I mean like
listen what I really learned from the
interview uh with with Pandora was
there's really nothing to be worried
about in this entire drag Panic that
there is
yeah as if I didn't already know that
but you know
sure I mean there's nothing to work
there's nothing to worry about there
really is exactly and um you know I I
one of one of your other colleagues
earlier talked about uh George Santos
and how you talk about I I call her
Katara ravage because I I'm a part-time
drag queen so I have no problem calling
her by her drag name okay I understand
why you didn't want to but just letting
you know I would I would call her Katara
and I will continue to call her guitar
all right Johnny you do you my friend I
appreciate that all right
David appreciate all right there is
Johnny from Boston always great to hear
from him let's go next to Joshua from
Portugal one of my favorite countries
in Western Europe Joshua from Portugal
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
then honored to be back on after a long
time it's a pleasure
welcome I was just actually sorry no I
was just welcoming you
oh thank you I was just asking like it's
kind of it's more like these recent days
I'm looking more and more like an
American politics and I'm looking
outside as a European of course and I've
always like baffled confused and just
sad about everything that's going on and
compared to how Europe's going I feel
like worried for some of my friends who
live in the states What specifically
worries you
uh school shooting the rise of the far
rights far right such as sorry
um Maga the proud boys and all that jazz
it's so worrisome because if it's so
easy to just fix some of these issues
well coming from a European like school
shootings for example yes like the
recent school shooting that happened in
Florida a few days ago
it's kind of sad that I I'm gonna be
honest I'm always gonna little meld out
about it because of how it's a constant
thing it's hard no listen it's hard not
to get desensitized to anything that's
happening constantly because one of the
things humans do is we adapt and uh I am
I agree with you I am aware myself of
becoming desensitized to a lot of the
insane things that are going on and to
some degree it happens with the
shootings too
Joshua
all right Joshua's gone
um we could have delved more into it but
we lost Joshua let's continue here why
don't we go next to Ike from Lagos Ike
from Lagos welcome to the program
Ike are you with us here sir
Ike from Lagos welcome
Ike you probably have the law the wrong
audio device selected so let's see if
you could fix it because I would love to
speak to somebody from Lagos but it's
not clear if it's going to work for us
today
all right and a failure with Ike from
Legos let's go to I've I'm not familiar
with this name is it Juan fer from
Portland
hey David hi
yes uh I I live in Portland Oregon I'm a
I'm an immigrant from Quito Ecuador and
I love that you have a Spanish YouTube
channel thank you yeah we are we are
doing everything we can with it I know
some people are continuing to insist
that really I should be doing the the
Clips in Spanish I just don't have the
time but I did record a beautiful
message in Spanish which we will soon be
publishing on the channel explaining all
of it but I think the channel is coming
along nicely
so you know
um coming in into the U.S I have to
learn about the the political climate
here because in South America every
politician every bad politician every
even
every politician is from the left so we
have people like Rafael Correa and Petra
and Maduro which are really corrupt and
are making their countries
like you cannot live there anymore
the the salary in uh
in Venezuela
I'm sorry the salary of Venezuela is is
equivalent to four dollars a month
yes I'm aware of that now the purchasing
power is of course different
yeah so
um
I really like to thank you because you
have helped shape my political opinion
of how the the left is is helping
everybody in this country and underwrite
the Republicans are trying to stop
everything of value
I appreciate that uh I uh and doing what
I can to the extent that I am able but
it's going to take a lot more than just
me that's for sure so we've got to keep
building the movement and getting people
involved I think is the critical part
yeah well thank you Dave for taking my
call all right thank you very much great
to hear from folks from all over the
world and all over the country we're
going to take a quick break but I am
taking more calls right after this short
break so if you're waiting to talk to me
and you've got a few more minutes just
hang on we'll go right back to the
phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show we're
continuing to hear from folks in the
audience we do these calls via Discord
you can find the David Pacman show
Discord at davidpackman.com Discord for
everybody who's waiting to talk to me
remember in your nickname you must have
your name and your location so folks I
see with like just a nickname or a
handle or whatever you aren't going to
be called on just so you know what the
what the guidelines are for example we
will go to Justin from New Jersey name
and location in that perfect format I
mentioned Justin from New Jersey welcome
what's on your mind
hey David uh it's first time Colin here
and uh I just wanted to ask you a few
quick questions sure you have a few
questions interesting
uh first of all is do you watch any
anime
I've only ever seen one anime movie it
was like 15 years ago it's called
Spirited Away
I don't think I ever heard of that okay
um
all right um into the political
questions
um
so do you think Rhonda Sanchez is
actually not going to run is that a
possibility I think it's a possibility
but an unlikely one I do believe
DeSantis is going to run it is very
difficult to have a 19 Point win for
governor for re-election to see yourself
polling very well without even having
announced and then to get away from it
because you never know when this
opportunity might present itself again
so I do think DeSantis is ultimately
going to run
because I I think it's interesting
because I can't see a world where Trump
doesn't win honestly I mean listen I
don't just I also think the most likely
scenario is Trump wins the primary
because I really do see him as a very
popular person regardless of if it's
DeSantis Nikki Haley or Tim Scott I feel
like the more people actually it just
helps Trump because he has a solid face
compared to these other people that
don't
where I am most
confident that Trump will best DeSantis
is once if and when it becomes a
national campaign with the insults and
the nicknames and the rhetoric
DeSantis is so uncharismatic
and even though they're a republican
insiders that are sick of trump or never
liked Trump I think the imagery of trump
making fun of DeSantis and uncharismatic
DeSantis not really being up to the task
of of punching back I think it's going
to be very tough for DeSantis to win
very tough
I I can agree with that thank you so
much all right Justin from New Jersey
great to hear from you let's go next to
Dean from Dallas Dean from Dallas uh
welcome what's going on with you
hey David can you hear me yes I can
yeah I was just wondering you know
um I don't know it's just probably you
know my opinion but uh elections are so
exhausting and in purple States I don't
know why the legislatures haven't moved
towards
like uh ranked Choice voting it seems
like it would just eliminate a lot of
the
the political campaigning the exhaustion
the fatigue and say it would be the
fiscally responsible thing to do too
100 yeah I mean listen part of why our
campaigns get so out of control
is there's nothing that stops them from
being increasingly more expensive with
more and more money being spent in total
by all sorts of different entities and
groups and from them being longer and
longer in Congress where you're up for
re-election every two years you
essentially start campaigning as soon as
you're sworn in you you win in November
you're sworn in in January and by March
you're already campaigning for your next
election and
um if we had I mean listen it probably
wouldn't be good for shows like mine and
people that depend on the interest and
the Intrigue but I it still would be
better for the country
if we had public financing limited
duration and compressed this thing
dramatically I do think it would be much
better for the country
so do you think it's because of a
financial incentive that places like
Georgia they just have an incentive to
keep running it because people just
funnel money into that State trying to
advertise yeah that's a big that's a big
part of it and the other thing is you
know there are certain states which
uh it's not that they become trendy but
due to circumstance like in 2020 Georgia
had the two special elections I don't do
you remember where if they on January
5th because of the 50 threshold Rule and
then in 2022 you had Marjorie Taylor
green and then you had Stacey Abrams
versus Brian Kemp and then you also had
the Herschel Walker wackiness so
sometimes States almost become like a
magnet where they start attracting
attention and money and Etc and it
doesn't mean that the state is
disproportionately important but it does
just start to become sort of like a show
more than other states all of that stuff
could be limited by some of the things
you're talking about yeah it almost
seems like kind of like a state
narcissism or something it's like all
eyes are on Pennsylvania or all eyes are
on Georgia yes and then after that
election and then everyone forgets about
them it's just like they're off the map
a hundred percent one hundred percent
and um I'm trying to think of examples
where a state was like big uh and that
will I mean like Ohio is an interesting
example where for several election
Cycles like I want to say 2000 2004 and
into 2008 everything was about Ohio
Ohio's a Bellwether all these different
things and then more recently there's
very little talk about Ohio as the
important place for presidential
candidates so you know these things
change over time it's all uh sort of
like a game and I would love to see some
of the restrictions on our elections
that you're talking about
uh well thank you for taking my call my
pleasure there is Dean from Dallas uh
with uh great great topics today I have
to say why don't we go next to Cody from
Atlanta Cody from Atlanta welcome to the
program today
Cody from Atlanta you're muted you have
to unmute yourself
and last chance for Cody from Atlanta I
can't unmute you you have decided to
mute yourself and thus I am unable to
hear you
all right Cody from Atlanta it's not
going particularly well today let's
instead go to is it Lincoln from Boston
or Boston from Lincoln it really could
be either
Lincoln from Boston Lincoln from Boston
welcome to the program
it's great to be here I wanted to ask
you about the 2024 election Lincoln are
you originally from Boston
I was born in Massachusetts about like
25 minutes south of Boston but yes
interesting because I detected a very
slight like almost like a Canadian
accent there
uh no Canadian here okay I mean it
wouldn't be an insult by the way Canada
is a beautiful place but all right go on
Lincoln
well so uh it is my understanding that
in 2020
when Joe Biden and the Democratic party
won the presidential election okay a lot
of that was due to events transpiring
that year namely covet of course and the
George Floyd protests
and I'm worried
in 2024
unfortunately it's awful to say this but
if there isn't major events like that
that take place I'm worried the
Democratic party won't have
um that fuel to to win so I don't know
that I necessarily agree with the
premise as far as the George Floyd
protest I don't know how big of a factor
the George Floyd protests were in
Biden's when I do think Trump's
mishandling of kovid was a hundred
percent a factor in Joe Biden's win but
I generally agree with your conclusion
which is you're worried about Biden's
ability to win in 24 and here's my view
on that
it's much
how can I say this you're at an
advantage in terms of how you can
campaign if you're not currently in
power and so even though we know that
Trump accomplished nothing of value
while he was President we know that
Trump made all sorts of promises that he
could never possibly keep we know all
these things right but the fact that Joe
Biden has been in power and if Trump is
the nominee he will have been out of
power or if Ron DeSantis is the nominee
he will never have been president they
can attack Biden in a particular way
that you can't when you're the person in
charge I think it's a benefit to whoever
is the eventual Republican nominee and I
have significant concerns about whether
Biden would win that election I don't
know that any Democrat would necessarily
win
uh in that situation when Democrats have
been in power but I do think that it's
going to be an uphill battle
I appreciate that answer um
just something I'm worried about and uh
yeah I mean I guess my premise um I
wasn't totally certain whether the
George Floyd protests and the covid-19
pandemic both contributed to Biden's win
that was just kind of my understanding
of what happened that year yeah but uh
thank you very much all right my
pleasure there is a Lincoln from Boston
with an extraordinary
um assessment I would say to some degree
let's go next to I don't know if it's
nitin or nitten from uh New York
however it is pronounced I hope that we
can figure it out welcome to the program
hey David this is nitin here from New
York though I'm currently in
Pennsylvania that's still allowed
no problem I just had a quick question
about Trump's history of frivolous
lawsuits yeah what does he get out of
from them like why does he like
typically file him you know especially I
remember you know him filing around 65
or so frivolous lawsuits that were all
like laughed out out of left and right
Etc in in court but you're saying in
response to the 2020 election does he
aim to do so there's different
categories
yeah there's different categories of
these lawsuits the 65 or 63 or whatever
the number was filed in response to the
2020 election
he needed to file those because he was
raising money on I'm going to be doing
this and I'm going to be fighting to
turn it over and whatever if he raises
all this money and then files nothing it
doesn't look quite so good so he was
filing them because he was raising money
to do it now the lawsuits were like
Jesus big tech for 300 million or
whatever the case may be those seem more
like virtue signaling than they are for
for sort of like grifting purposes so
you have to look specifically at which
ones you're talking about
got you but you know but in general like
you know I looked up his legal
strategies and you know like for the
most part it's mainly about you know
harassing opponents just to intimidate
them or like you know using it as a
stall tactic 100 that is absolutely what
it is about in many cases many times
it's counter suits to prevent some
lawsuit against him from moving forward
there's like a real all of the above
sort of situation going on with them but
um they seem to be relatively
ineffective at least in the last five
years
gotcha yeah
all right anything else today
tell it uh nothing else all right very
good I appreciate the call your videos
okay Nathan Newton from York we're
starting to get a bit of a delay that
was causing some awkward exchanges I'm
sorry I wasn't able to get to everyone
but I will try to do better next time
really great hearing from many folks in
the audience we are going to take a
quick break and the Friday show will
continue
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right it is time for Friday feedback
we're calling it Friday feedback now
instead of the mailbag because we are
just regularly incorporating elements
that aren't actually emails and as you
know I want both precision and Clarity
and it is not really accurate to call it
the email bag when we are highlighting
elements from Facebook or Reddit or
YouTube or whatever the case may be so
same stuff new name Friday feedback all
right let's get right into it starting
with some critiques to put it lightly
Wanda wrote in and Wanda says you and
your page must be a comedian slash
comedy because to think Biden is brave
and has done anything good for this
country is sad and blinded well Wanda
you win an award
you are a Critic
who used the correct form of your versus
your correctly using y-o-u-r to show
possession it is my page
I used to say it is almost a requirement
that you use the wrong your when you
write in with hate mail
but Wanda used the correct one now in
terms of Biden is brave and has done
anything good there is a long list of
good things that Joe Biden has done
we've talked about it and it is a very
wide-ranging inflation reduction act
coveted stimulus the attempt to do some
student loan debt relief although it's
now tied up in court getting out of
Afghanistan I think going to Ukraine was
a super interesting and politically
Savvy thing to do laying the Trap around
Social Security and Medicare which
completely upended the way Republicans
were talking about I mean there's a very
long list of things that Joe Biden has
done is he my favorite President is he
the best president was he my number one
pick no but we're trying to be adults
here Wanda please
uh and such black and white thinking is
very very sad Susan wrote in also on
Facebook this is so damn funny I'm gonna
tell you what's going on here okay Susan
wrote to me stay off my effing page
libtard
following it up with Trump 47 go Brandon
and then put by dumb in a nursing home
jail with Hillary Clinton and the Obama
boys Obama yeah
this is a thing that happens a lot there
are non-tech Savvy right-wingers who
don't understand how algorithms work and
as many of you know if you regularly
watch videos on Facebook you might be
scrolling this is me scrolling on my
phone you might be scrolling
and then you're looking at Facebook
video
and it's just showing you things it's
showing you things algorithmically it's
showing you things randomly it's just
showing you stuff and if you don't like
something and you're sort of like a
normal person you just scroll past it
there are people on the right who will
contact us on Facebook who seem to think
that we need to remove our content from
their quote page and that's where you
end up with stuff like this stay off my
effing page libtard now Susan could just
press I don't like this and then she
would never see our content again but a
lot of tech confusion as to you know
yeah I'm sitting here saying show Susan
my Clips Facebook please dear God
Michael wrote in about media coverage of
the grand jury four person in Georgia in
that Trump related uh grand jury and
Michael said David love the show keep up
the great work why isn't anyone talking
about media coverage of Emily Coors CNN
literally aired an interview of Miss
core's diver divulging inappropriate
grand jury information then proceeded to
lambast her actions as irresponsible on
Anderson Cooper I would expect a
reputable news Outlet to know better
than to broadcast such inappropriate and
sensitive information does the media
bear responsibility I don't think so no
I think you know if media
Outlets say we're not going to name Mass
Shooters because there's like a specific
reason to avoid glorifying and giving
them the fame that they seek
I think that's totally fine and legit to
say we aren't going to
show
newsworthy stuff that someone else has
chosen to provide
because of how it might impact a case
even though there's no legal issue I I
just see it as very different I don't
think CNN is doing anything wrong it
should be up to the jury for person to
decide is it appropriate for me to speak
or not and for whatever
uh Court related authorities to
um manage that but I don't think media
Outlets are doing anything wrong by
showing the interviews Derek also wrote
in about Emily cores and says sounds
like someone close to Trump got to this
woman more tampering nobody in their
right mind would think this is a good
idea except Trump a few people did write
in and say you know David it occurred to
me
that maybe this was something someone on
the Trump side encouraged Emily cores to
do this bizarre media tour knowing it
would be useful to Trump
it's I I understand why people are
making the suggestion uh I have no
evidence that that's what happened but
it would be interesting to look into it
Dean wrote to me about Donald Trump's
plant I think it means plan to eliminate
crime and says hey David someone should
ask Trump if he could eliminate crime in
the U.S why didn't he eliminate crime in
the U.S during his four years in office
you know it's a perfectly reasonable and
sensible question but if you presented
it to Trump trump would say
that it was because of Democrats
Democrats blocked him from doing it but
if you vote him in next time he'll have
the House and Senate and this time
Democrats won't be able to block him or
you know we often feel in politics that
we have these gotchas and of course
Dean's question is a hundred percent
reasonable why like if why are you now
saying you're going to do all these
great things which you couldn't or
didn't do during your first term they
have an answer they have an end the
point is their followers will accept
that answer
Kevin wrote to me and said David do you
have any advice in regards to particular
methods you find useful to keep yourself
strong in the face of constant terrible
news with Flint Michigan now Ohio it's
become very apparent to me we're on our
own
our leaders Don't Care About Us at all I
find it disgusting that Democrats are
unwilling to speak up at all about Ohio
I don't know that's true and they let
Trump swoop in and act like he gives an
S about anybody other than himself it
was a good move Trump pulled going there
makes him look good it's hard to remain
hopeful when it seems like fascism is
about to fully take hold and has no real
opposition whatsoever keep it up David
hopefully the internet remains intact
and you can continue to upload it's
important to know what's going on
honestly I know that a lot of people
aren't going to like this but honestly
here is what I recommend to keep
yourself sane understand
there's a limit to the number of issues
you as an individual can fix and for
health reasons it's really important to
say this is going to be my intake of
this stuff and that's going to be it you
I've said for me unless I'm like
streaming something on the weekend from
the time I'm done with the Friday show
until I start working on the Monday show
I pay no attention to news and politics
and it is really healthy to set those
limits because you're right Kevin
otherwise it becomes overwhelming in
that way
Ellen wrote in and says David you set
out all the reasons why it wouldn't make
sense for Trump to sign the Republican
loyalty pledge but we all know he
doesn't think rules apply to him ever my
guess is it wouldn't bother him to at
least in the least to sign the Loyalty
pledge when it benefited him by getting
him on stage and then turn right around
and run as a third party candidate if it
suits him he'll have no trouble at all
true thing that it was a plot by the
rhinos and he's not bound by it Ellen's
completely correct then in fact I uh
mentioned this on the Monday show
Trump's most likely scenario is if he
has to sign the pledge to debate he'll
do it and then if he loses and wants to
run third party he'll do it and when
people say well but what about that
loyalty pledge sir
he'll say
it doesn't apply because they rigged it
and they stole it and whatever
thorsten wrote in about me taking time
off and says Dear David sir I'm a great
fan of your show and just saw the
mailbag video that's the reason I want
to say something positive about your
supporting your Replacements none of
them are as good as you are that's
because it's your show but all of them
did a very good job it's extremely hard
to replace the front runner of a show
even for a short time of vacation or
parental leave everybody has his own
voice style way of speaking of declaring
something I think you did a good job
with the picks well I appreciate that
and then lastly from TB or TBM
hello David I wish to thank you for not
starting your broadcast with the word so
I've begun to avoid sites that do use of
so to start a broadcast is as sloppy as
what's up everyone
both of these rank up there with at this
point in time or In This Moment both of
which drive me to distraction laziness
has no place in journalism I'm pleased
the malaise hasn't infected your
programs yeah so I guess that would be
like if I started a show with something
like uh
so Donald Trump did another crazy thing
I guess I don't do that I've never I've
never noticed people in general doing
that
but to the extent that TB likes that I
don't start my episodes with so
I am at your service TV TB thank you
very much for uh for letting me know
remember you may be featured in Friday
feedback if you respond to me on Twitter
leave a YouTube comment respond on
Facebook whatever the case may be and
you also of course can continue to email
info
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say we also now have the David
packman show in Spanish with where are
we from the standpoint of subscribers
where are we doing on Spanish
right around the 2000 Mark yeah so we
are building the Spanish Channel it is
the same content dubbed into Spanish for
folks who prefer to consume the content
in Spanish you can go to
davidpackman.com
Spanish to find the channel and I will
see you uh next week and uh producer
Pat's on the bonus show today he'll see
you in a moment
foreign